بعد ما انتظرت هذه اللحظه 40 عاما احتضنت
والده الاسير الحاجه وداد يونس البالغ من
العمر
88 عاما نجلها اليوم لاول مره
شعور لا لا يوصف بعد 40 سنه
بعد ان امضيات طفولتهما سويا في قريه
زملاء في السجن ل 40 عاما اليوم يلتقيان
وهما يتنفسان الحريه
هذا شعور لا يوصف وان كنا يعني لا يمكن
الوصفه يعني كل اللغه العربيه لا يمكن وصف
الشعور هذا ايه شعور طبعا طيب والاستقبال
ما شاء الله الحمد لله شفت الاهل وشفت
الاصدقاء ومن عاشروني في الاسير يعني كمان
اصدقاء وكنا كنت انا بالبيت عندهم وهو من
بيت عنا واحنا كمان تعلمنا سوا في نفس
المدرسه والاخره وتغربنا سوا وكمان رفاق
نضال بدنا نروح عند زميل او صديق مشترك
وحسناتنا
انه يمكن نزور بيوت اسرى اخرين حنظرهم ان
شاء الله سوا بعد ان وجهها ماهر رساله
للشعب الفلسطيني
التي تهتف باسمي فلسطين
عشرات الفلسطينيين اتو من القدس وام الفحم
وعكا والمدن المجاوره لتقديم التهاني
والتبريكات للاسير ماهر يونس على الرغم من
قرار وزير الامن القومي المتطرف اتمرن
كبير منعم مظاهر الاحتفال ورفع الاعلام
الفلسطينيه احتفل عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين
بتحرير الاسير ماهر يونس والذي امضى
اربعين عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه لا
نقول غازي من قريه عراء العربيه